cool hi everyone again so I yes this
talk is called Project in machine
learning as i said in my previous talk
it was going to be a list of projects as
i thought you know be really nice to
have some subset projects but but this
one took me long enough and and i wanted
to do is start the finished thing in but
now I've got less time so yeah Oh
hopefully I don't run out of battery
power okay so right what I wanted to do
is make a amazon classifier so what I
wanted to do is an artifact this is
going to be in the realms of of dvds in
this case movies because i just wanted
to keep it for the general to one topic
i could have extended it to every
product i suppose and seen how how the
text reflects the star rating in general
but basically what i wanted to do is
create some grand classifier for for
movies so you can feed it in a movie
review and Wolfram would determine with
this classifier what well rating you
would get so case you're unfamiliar by
the way this is a very this is in detail
so I apologize in advance if you're if
you're bored well this is this is Amazon
you hadn't seen it before and you know
we have a review and we this is a film
exodus which I've not seen but I can
look at the reviews and basically I want
to be able to extract these reviews and
use them in the classify and this is it
requires us to be able to go across the
URL because I don't know if Amazon have
an API but I just used our function you
are at effects to grab all these reviews
and I wanted a considerable number of
reviews as well so what do I so you need
to do so k so I need to find the data
source well the data sources amazon com
or Dakota UK in this case I want to
fetch the data when I fetch the data I
want to format it to data which the
Wolfram language
read more efficiently and then I want to
create a classifier predict i'll explain
in the end but predict would have been
better but i use to classify in this
case and then finally we just want to
analyze the accuracy of this and so we
can streamline streamline the classifier
a bit to make it a bit more accurate so
first you actually need the products so
what I actually used is I used the this
is weird I actually use the import diode
DOI pie we partner with them before and
they're very interesting very
interesting company but anyway I got
this this link of like the top so we
several hundred pages of reviews here we
can see is 860 7,000 DVDs that I could
that I could go through and I wanted a
reasonable number of movies i can't
remember how many i went for in the end
like a thousand movies or something like
that and we can see there's a URL and
first of all I wanted to extract the
movie the movie link so if I click on
this link it will bring up this page and
then I can extract the reviews from each
one so i used the employer api and i
just got it here read ready which has
this doesn't delete it which has a bunch
of a bunch of urls what we can see
actually from this from this URL is that
there's a page numbers involved so
there's a page two and then there's a
there's a page to hear so if i change
the page to to a page three then it will
go to the third page XX or accessory so
i can just cruel as many pages as I like
so in this case i'm just crawling over
the first 10 pages i think i ended up
crawling over like 200 as i said and i
can run this API and i just run these
queries and what I I there's a little
bit more work involved but basically
I've extracted all the movies and the
links associated with the movies for in
this case 72 movie so that's quite nice
i exported to a CSV
and then I imported it directly into the
into the language so this function this
this this variable Rev data which
already has all the reviews in and just
so you can see the format so it's very
text heavy because it's text analysis
I'll go the number of reviews associated
with that with that product and then the
page URL so there are 10 min URLs there
are 10 reviews per page so in this case
230 reviews will have 24 pages and so I
had to create another set of URLs in
this case it was about 24,000 URLs
because there were twenty four thousand
pages that i was going through to get
away in this case 170,000 reviews so
sifting through 120 2320 3641 pages
takes a little bit of time so i used
this function parallel map to use go map
across as many kernels as i as i as i
have access to and really you want to
map across as many kernels as you have
so i well I have eight so I just map
across a it doesn't matter that you've
only got four Colonels because you're
actually down along the time is spent
downloading downloading the page and
then you're doing this function string
cases to look basically for the review
text in this case here the review text
and the review the star rating which is
this naught 29.92 now I use the regular
expression you could use it in the in
you can need when you use string cases
you can use regular expressions or
Wolfram language string cases or I don't
know what we call patterns or something
like that's what we call them but I
would quite like regular expression so
you can choose I think used to finding
my code that i interchange depending on
how convenient it was so I grabbed all
this all this data and I don't directly
export them into MX files you can see
here that I export to a MX file with the
product name followed by the number you
don't have to understand all this but
but just so you know actually what's
happening so I made a bunch of MX bars
it's a good format for being
to re-import rien port data because it
imports as fast as possible basically
and then I so I recombine all the MX MX
files into one MX file and then export
it because the thing is when you're when
you're downloading so many pages of data
there might be some places where there's
failure and if there's failure in your
MX file then it can be a bit of a pain
so I extract that data first actually I
actually use cases to extract the data
and then I clean the data and I'll make
sure that the the the head of the second
element is is is a real number because
what we end up having is we end up
having the review text followed by the
star rating as a real number okay so now
I've got my 170,000 reviews ah that's it
you know I want to classify it so we
import the durian put the data because
you know it takes a while and then i
classify this data and i'm not going to
classify now because it takes about 50
seconds so I'm just going to import I
saved my classify as an MX file you can
save it as a wd X file as well WD X
Files have more Universal compatibility
with other with other machines whereas
MX files I think are limited to your
operating system don't quote me on that
though you can test if you want but I
can't remember what the specifics were
so we import this classifier we've got a
classify function which used markov
method with five classes one to five
stars text analysis with 170,000 reviews
so there's a function classifier
information to find out certain parts of
information of a of a classifier so here
you can see the class priors feature
names feature types training time etc so
I've used training time just to show you
how long it would have taken how long
you would have been sitting here waiting
and it's 60 seconds in this case and I'm
using showing you class prize as well
to show you basically kind of shows you
prior to reading a review what kind of
percentage waiting is there based on
based on some reviews now I took like
the top 200 reviews and you know with
the top 200 movies or 200 pages of
movies what you would expect is there's
a heavy waiting for five stars and less
441 start so we can see seventy two
percent was five and five percent was
one but I fed all the data in any way
now this is a bad thing I'll explained
it to you later but now we can test the
classifier so i can go i hated this
movie let me just make some space oh
dear so it's going on with five five
starts okay um I like I hate this movie
okay this movie was great five stars wow
that's surprising okay average movie oh
come on come on this is over okay okay
I've got I I pre-made some just in case
something bad happened okay right okay
so worst mood worst film ever one
greatest film of all time five a pretty
average field three okay so that's okay
but the thing is when you've got Amazon
reviews you've got a lot more words so
so I'm being very loose here I mean what
we could do is we could go to one of
these films i suppose and go let's grab
a two-star review and feed it in here
and see what happens so the two-star
review it reviewed as a three-star i'll
grab a five-star review and such a short
15 stars and we'll just give 11 star
just to see Tara okay maybe not maybe
not that one okay little something a
little bit more bit more words okay five
now that
okay so it's not but we want to see the
accuracy of this they don't trust I'll
you know I've given you a very small
small amount of data here so we want to
we want to analyze this data and to do
that we have this function classify
measurements so first of all I'm going
to sort all the reviews that I have into
groups of star rating so if I have a
look at data sorted 11 we can see that
this is the five-star group and if i go
to 21 it's the one star group 3 14 *
McKettrick tetris so I've grouped all
the all the data into into into groups
and basically I want to take a random
sample of a thousand reviews from one
star to star three star force star five
star so that's what sample the function
of the variable sample 1000 is and then
I want to use this this function
classify measurements which takes a set
of what a test set for your classifier
against your classifier so I've got my
classifier which I could see against my
5000 reviews and it gives me a
classifier measurements object and you
can see it used 5,000 examples for the
test to see how accurate it is at
determining the star ratings on this
thing and yeah the number of okay even
tells me here the accuracy was spoiled
it no let's let the Pretender didn't
happen so I can have a look at the
properties of this classifier object and
its various properties which you may or
may not be interested in or one of the
things that you can see is a confusion
matrix plot which is question this is
this basically tells us what the actual
the actual rating was against the
predicted rating where where things went
wrong so this can be really interesting
to understand where things are going
wrong so 972 examples in this case were
correctly predicted as five stars when
they work when they were five stars
we're in wrong here two examples of 5
stars are miscalculated as 102 stars
five stars we miscalculated is 2 and so
on and so forth so this this this area
is a bit sparse but we can see is in
this hot this vertical column is that
five stars seem to be there's a lot of
Miss classification when it comes to
five stars and the reason why is because
there's such a larger proportion of five
star ratings in this classified so this
is something that you need to be aware
of so we can have a look at the accuracy
in general in our measurements object we
can say what is the accuracy in this
case 46.2 percent so that means out of
all when it did all of these don't
remember there's a thousand of each
review so it's not like it's weighted
with with five stars as a thousand one
stars a thousand two stars three stars
etc etc so it's done a pretty good job
because if it was completely random then
it would be twenty percent accuracy
right so we've got some improvement here
and we can see in precision where things
go wrong the most so it says here that
that one star ratings have a sixty
percent accuracy success rate two stars
23 * 34 stars 22 and five stars 97 so it
does five stars very very well but
that's because it often miss classifies
everything as five stars so first of all
before i go into and to read of
redesigning our classifier a bit we want
to see what it looks like to how many
reviews would we need to get a hundred
percent accuracy i mean this is this is
ridiculous of course cos there's always
going to be that human human error but
let's have a look so first of all i need
to create classifiers at different well
I need to grab different sized samples
of for the classifier so I've got
samples of ten to a hundred thousand
classifies so I make a bunch of
classifiers oops I shouldn't run that
but I'll show you what the result was
just in case you you understand us
understand what I'm what I'm saying so
we've got all these classifiers so this
is like 10 we're with 10 samples this is
with 20 samples 30 samples and we can go
we go all the way up to a hundred
thousand so we've made all these
classified functions and we want to
determine the accuracy based on the
sample the test set that we had before
so I've already imported it actually so
now I want to create a bunch of classify
measurements for each of these
classifiers so for each classifier I
want to put that 5,000 5,000 samples
into the clash of our measurements
function and see how well the overall
accuracy is so this takes I don't think
it takes too long not nearly as long as
he is the other thing it does okay it's
finished and basically we're just going
to map on the on the classifier
measurement function the accuracy so we
want a mat we want to see the accuracy
from zero to a hundred thousand and we
can see that well I'll just I'll just
draw the plot so it's easier to
understand I should have put axes or
something like that but in the y-axis is
the number of reviews that we use for
the classifier and then on the x-axis is
the percentage accuracy and as we can
see that the accuracy goes up with more
more reviews the more data that there
actually is is you what we'd expect but
what we want to know is how much data do
we really need to extract to get a given
percentage accuracy I suppose well in
this size I've I've gone ridiculous and
I said 100% accuracy so I need to do a
model fit and here i'm doing a nonlinear
model fit of a exponential of bx and
what okay whatever i have time to look
at that but let's think hopefully if i
plot it it will look fine yep so I
plotted my fitted model which is 246 eat
ooh the 14.8 X and we can see how well
it fits it's not amazing i'm pretty sure
that that's wrong maybe you shouldnt
quote me on my statistics here
in some way but but but I I was guessing
on an exponential and if it's kind of ok
and in this case how many reviews do I
need for one hundred percent accuracy
well I grabbed the model and I say well
one is for a hundred percent and I need
6.5 times ten to the eighth reviews so
that's 653 million reviews right that I
require for one hundred percent accuracy
now why do we care about class priors
well I said previously that seventy two
percent of the results were essentially
five-star and how do we mitigate that
what you can do is you can normalize
your data and just grab you know 10,000
one-star 10,000 to star 10,000 three
starts hitter etc but when your sample
size is big enough you don't have to do
that and we can just say the class
priors are equally weighted so prior to
actually doing any classification we're
saying that there's an equal probability
that each classifier is a certain you
know that is going to be a one-star it's
to a two-star eccentric cetera so used
class priors to make another thing this
is very similar to I did before I just
quickly test okay test okay does does
three stars best movie 5 stars worst
movie come on one star so it's not a
little bit better maybe and now I I do a
parallel map here of the same thing I
did before so ten to a hundred thousand
reviews and I haven't really done any
cleaning here because I was a little bit
lazy so there's some errors here because
some of the classified numbers don't
actually exist anymore because when the
date when the sample size is too small
like 10 reviews your your the likelihood
of you having because I randomly grab
the data when it came to the
classification that they may not be a
one star or two star review in the
sample size that small so that happened
in one in one instance here but don't
worry about that just it doesn't matter
i clean the data so I've just ran I
import the data and I grab my multiple
classifiers and you can see the
classifiers that failed are these ones
here and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to strip them out because they're
not very important anyway because the
sample
I was so small so I do the same thing as
before I grab the classify measurements
from 10 to 100 thousand reviews again
ignoring these and ignoring these errors
and then I want to figure out what the
accuracy is so the priors accuracy I
need to clean the data first here we go
so I do some some cleaning of the data
and then I find out what the accuracy
actually was from from zero to hundred
thousand i will put it into a plot for
you so that you can see and we can see
that well i don't know what we can see
now we can see something very similar to
what we saw before and I'll fit a model
like it did before this time I actually
used the the define formula function in
10.2 to figure out what what formula was
best for fitting and in this case it
said it was B times X to the five so I'm
going to do not only model fit and it
says 3.4 times x 10 to the 6 X to the
five and then I'll combine this data and
we'll see this fit looks a lot better so
this is this is this is quite nice and
then with my with my model i should i do
it later so i mention it now so just
just look at that think it looks nice
sure here we are now just grabbing the
classifier measurements of the of the
big classify so we've got 170,000
reviews and we're getting the classifier
measurements of 5,000 of 5,000 test
examples as we did before and then we
just want to find the accuracy so
actually the maximum maximum accuracy
that we have here for 170,000 reviews is
fifty-six percent aware as before we had
40-something percent and we can see the
confusion matrix plot actually I'll just
compare it to the previous one so that
it's a bit it's a bit easier for you to
understand so the one on the left is the
confusion matrix plot from not doing
class priors I Statler normal
in class prize and the one on the right
is where we done class price so we can
see that on this this this vertical
column on the right for five stars it's
much better when it comes to miss
classification of five stars and
therefore we get a more accurate result
so yeah so yeah so the accuracy is
fifty-six percent and the accuracy of
the original one with was forty-six
percent and then just to show you prove
to you that well is the accuracy of the
class prize more than the accuracy of
the original it returns true so so no
mistakes have been made here which is
great so one of the things in this what
you'll see in this in this in this in
this dot in this list plot is I did not
include the maximum the maximum value
which had 170 thousand reviews because I
wanted to show you based on my model how
accurate my model actually is so here my
model for fifty five percent accuracy
actually was 56 was go fifty six point
three eight percent requires 193,000
reviews and a number of reviews that I
actually had were 170,000 so it's quite
close and we can see the precision as
well and this is this is actually quite
interesting because we see that one star
seventy percent accurate five stars
ninety percent accurate three stars 50
and then it gets a little bit inaccurate
with twos and twos and fours and the
reason why is because I guess that's
probably a bit more as a bit more harder
to read and so yeah okay so anyway so I
did fifty five percent accuracy requires
a hundred this is this is old data so we
said 193,000 reviews how many do we
acquire for a hut for for 100% accuracy
and in this case we require 3.4 million
results as opposed to 300 and 480
million or whatever it's okay anyway
that's that's that in conclusion
ah the mass extraction of data maybe you
didn't find that simple i found it
simple but but it's relatively easy to
too cruel a website with with the
Wolfram language the classify with no
knowledge of how to actually use it it's
actually reasonably accurate but if we
do some simple that was a simple
optimization there I actually increase
the accuracy by ten percent if you try
predict actually you would get a better
result in general because you know you
get if something was between four and
five stars it would be four and three so
maybe the data will be a bit more
relevant so 56% is more than the forty
six percent is more than the twenty
percent that you would have gotten and
then 3.2 million reviews is much less
than eight hundred and five million
review service quiet now last thing
plums talk tomorrow and I'm not just
plugging my boss for extra points but
he's giving a talk about the data
science platform to 15 and the Dow room
and basically he's going to be showing
the classifier action so this classifier
that I've used is used to generate a
report which you'll be able to you do
you'll be able to interact with in the
cloud which is really cool so I don't
have time to show now and it was
designed to be in that talk tomorrow so
there's more information about how that
was done so great thank you very much
for listening